foreign
[Music]
Staten Island it's date night for Kim
Kardashian and Pete Davidson it's a
different experience for sure on
Saturday everyone's new favorite couple
was seen out and about in Pete's
Hometown fans first spotted the pair at
the movies where they were joined by
Scott Disick and the night didn't end
there as they were apparently in the
mood for some Italian it was calming a
local restaurant shared these photos to
Instagram on Sunday you can see Pete Kim
and Scott posing in some selfies the
caption reads quote thank you Kim
Kardashian Pete Davidson Scott Disick
and others for having dinner at
Angelina's last night truly great to
serve come back anytime of course Pete's
night off was courtesy of Saturday night
Live's last minute change of plans
I know it wasn't a Christmas show that
you expected but that's the beauty of
this place like life it's unpredictable
just hours before Showtime SNL announced
most of the cast and crew were staying
home due to increased covet concerns yes
I am here and this is not the smallest
audience I have ever performed for
because I have done improv in a Macy's
the day night also follows Kim recently
filing legal documents to be declared
legally single a move that comes amid
her ongoing divorce from Kanye West Kim
filed for divorce earlier this year
after six years of marriage meanwhile
Kanye is sending messages that he wants
to reconcile I'm rolling with it at the
rappers free Larry Hoover benefit
concert and with Kim sitting in the
audience Kanye changed a lyric in his
song Runaway that was pretty telling
[Music]
more specifically
but Kim's focus seems to be directed
elsewhere if her birthday gift to Pete
last month is any indication well see
let me tell you when it comes down to
Pete Davidson and Kim Kardashian
first of all to me that's family and the
Flavor Flav gave E.T the full back story
to this epic photo I was so honored to
be in their presence one thing that I
could say Pete Davidson loves himself
some Flavor Flav everything he does is
Flavor Flav this Flavor Flav that Flavor
Flav this Flavor Flav that's so Kim said
okay well for your birthday you're gonna
have Flavor Flav
so she sent for me
and that's how I ended up there you know
what I'm saying I want to know something
is this is this is this relationship
real what's going on with him and Kim
well see let me say this when it comes
down to Pete Davidson and Kim
Kardashian's relationship you know what
I'm saying only them two know it best
you know what I'm saying they just
invited me into the circle you know what
I'm saying but I really don't know the
full you know and plus besides man I I
mean you know that's Kim and Pete man I
would rather them tell about that
situation than me
foreign